if you can see this please type
hi thank you names
this much like the last one it's some
somewhat of a test
all right hi
so how did you like the Avi episode
if there's something that stuck out to
you I'd like to know
thank you
yes great great I hope you enjoy it
thank you thank you
yes Bruce thank you thank you for
sharing that with me
yes it was new to him I
I believe it was new
hi T car
you're always a trooper man thank you
yes Jake I'm I'm happy about that as
well
so
what guests
would you most like to see
and what types of conversations would
you most likely would you most like to
see so for myself I like the math and
physics conversation conversations most
for you all and
for you I would like to know
by the way I have to get going shortly
because I'm speaking at the California
Institute for integral studies so I have
to leave in five minutes
as I have to prepare for that this week
I completely overbooked usually I
usually I have one podcast in a week and
that takes up all almost all of my time
and this week I had four podcasts plus
I'm speaking at this place so five
geez
who's coming up next is Nick Lane that
should be Tuesday Wednesday Thursday or
Friday I'm unsure
I need to go through Alex's theories
um
I
don't believe so he didn't do so to me
at least
sorry let me state that with my voice in
case some people are listening t-car
asks did Avi ever mention about getting
a Gates donation and I said no
not to me I don't know if he has
hey the memes of Destruction
I don't know how to pronounce that but
names jsr says please share any links
that I have to my speeches on other
channels
there is on the Discord there's a link
to all of the podcasts that I have on
other people's platforms and just so you
know I generally don't like doing
podcasts on other people's platforms I
don't like to be the guest because I
don't have much to say and I'm nervous
terribly nervous
and I just don't feel as if I'm adding
much and it also takes me away from
studying toes which is what I I just
love to study
but some people seem to like them and it
helps me clarify my own thoughts
so I am also grateful simultaneously
while I dislike it I'm averse to it but
I like it
thank you T car yes I will I will
respond to that soon and I do have many
projects many many projects coming up so
I'd like to let you know about them and
see if you can help out
one idea that I have that I need to do
is I need to get a full-time editor so
that it's not just me editing all of
these now I do have an editor who does a
first pass but then I go through and I
fine-tune and then I make the timestamps
and then I edit and then I upload and
then I make the thumbnail and then I I
have to re-upload for an audio platform
that I have to take out the sponsor
message and give that to the ad manager
so they can place it on a different
platform and there's so much tediousness
that goes into it that it's almost well
there's no point in me doing it but I
don't have anyone else and I would like
to hire that out I would like to get to
the point where I can hire that out then
I can produce podcasts much more
frequently with the same quality if not
greater quality and it would improve my
own mental health my own mental
well-being because I'm not working so
hard not stressed rendering oh my gosh
geez when I render I'm just looking at
this there are many errors here and
there then I have to go and re-render
and then I have to wait another three
hours for the it's it's frustrating it's
so so frustrating anyway I would like to
Outsource all of that
Yes actually unseeker just emailed me
we're speaking he's going to be
submitting to the PACE contest and he's
an upcoming guest as for exactly when
I'm unsure
thank you yes it is plenty of work
plenty of work
maybe I'm not sure shorty bear
sounds like it could be our own
foolishness though I think of the Turing
test as not a not of a test of
the capabilities of the computer but a
test of our own ignorance so for example
if you give a Tamagotchi to a
five-year-old they may think that it's
just as alive as them but that's we see
that as a
remark not about the tamagotchi's
intelligence but a remark about the lack
of a self model of the five-year-old so
the Turing test to me doesn't doesn't
imply sentience necessarily it just
implies our own limited model
have I been on Lexus or rogans or asked
no I've emailed Lex a few times and I
haven't heard back I imagine that he's
extremely busy or that he well I imagine
that he's extremely busy I have nothing
but respect for for Lex and for Rogan to
create such a large show from he created
the podcast space holy moly like he
created an entire genre essentially long
form podcasts
Travis Taylor is a guest yeah I would
like to I need to speak to him I believe
we exchanged one email
I'm unsure I think so I think we
exchanged an email
tikar are more than happy to help yes
please thank you I am very much
that would be ex well by being debted to
you thank you
with avi's emergent property I don't
know it depends on what the term
illusion means and then he may have a
different definition
I don't know
if what he means by emergent property is
a
is an illusion I'm reading it because
some people are listening
yes yeah I agree we had a great great
conversation
I
yes yeah I I like when I can go into
someone's work and just delve into it
for weeks or for at least one week and
then just speak to them and just flow
through this conversation rather than
have a bullet point set list of
questions from the audience so I've
backed off from that the more AMA Styles
you can see the old UFO videos for Ama
ask me any things from the audience and
that was because of my relative lack of
knowledge in the subject I had no idea
what were the correct questions or sorry
competent questions to ask
and then I was excoriated at least by
some for asking foolish questions which
I still don't think were particularly
foolish but but I understand that
that if you
have certain knowledge about what UFOs
can or
or can't be or or should or shouldn't be
or what the conversation should be like
then you feel like asking a question
about
a crash landing at Roswell is too
simplistic I understand that I am too
simplistic to see why that's a simple
question I mean two sorry not uh jejun
question a naive question
okay well I gotta get going because I
have a
I'm speaking at this place called the
California Institute for integral
studies so if there's some public link
to that I'll let you all know but I
don't think it's public
thank you thank you Chris
okay well I appreciate you all coming
out and something you should know is
that there's a theories of
everything.org website that's just been
launched and that's a place where if you
don't want to support patreon because
patreon takes a cut or you don't like
the business practices of patreon then
there's a website that we created so
that we could have control over the
people who donate us not the control
over you but I mean control over the
fact that you're donating
whereas patreon can shut you off can
shut a Creator off at any moment for
whatever reason they like that's part of
the terms and services
we created theories of everything.org
don't go to.com there's a cyber squatter
who has that but dot org so you can go
there more of the funds go to myself
and there are several benefits like an
ad free audio version and also that
version should come out prior to
premiering on YouTube
and you'll get a number to text me so
like to phone text me if if you're into
that
you'll get a place to submit AMA
questions you'll get
discounts to the Live Events when we
finally do have them there's quite a few
benefits so go to
theoriesofeverything.org if you'd like
to be a member there but if not doesn't
matter hey you watching that's
that's more than enough support thank
you all for coming out and watching the
Avi
interview I gotta get going
I don't want to be late for this take
care everyone
okay let's see if I can quickly tell you
some of what's
what's going to happen hmm
okay
let's see
so anziger I imagine unsecker I know I
don't mean to mispronounce your name if
you're watching this I'm sorry so
unzucker will come on
hopefully this year if if the timing
works out between the both of us Clee
Irwin as well Frank Yang as well so this
is being announced here and not on the
theories of everything.org website
I'm just doing this because hey you're
here live there's so many plans for the
future then there's Nick Lane who's a
biologist that's coming up and I may
start to delve more into biology Nick
Lane and Michael Levin are making me so
excited about studying the whole field
that I've always
pushed off to the side because of the
undue amount of memorization that needs
to occur before you get some semblance
of what's occurring biologically there's
so many words and there's so many
verbs and
physics is extremely simple at least
comparatively to biology but biology is
extremely interesting especially origin
of life
okay then
John verviki and Ian mcgilchrist are
coming on together later John braviki
and Donald Hoffman will come on together
the end of November so there's so many
so many oh yeah to modeling is tomorrow
okay all right I gotta get going take
care everyone thank you thank you